.
Thank you.
This is kind of refreshing for me because this is the way the committee room was always supposed to look to me.
I remember that.
And that in the old days, when we did subcommittees, we would just all sit down at that end.
But a committee conference was this, looking across from each other.
So this is nice to have this on our final day.
Well, good morning.
So good morning.
All right.
So do you want us to start?
I get, yeah.
I mean, I assume we're all set now, right?
Yeah, we're going to take 354 and 555 off it and pass it 1380 as is right so the motion will be a c to the house position period yep appreciate it very much yep thank you very much um all those in favor of that motion please say aye aye i suppose.
And we're all set.
Awesome.
Thanks.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for having me.
Always a pleasure.
That was really good.
We'll see you in Ringe sometime.
Yes, sir.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
this bill without the military installation.
So to see how you guys are with this.
I would say that in terms of if you're not willing to take it off and we're not willing to sign off on it, it would be the underlying bill, the liquor bill, has a big impact on almost every beverage manufacturer in the state because they all go into these tenant and contract manufacturing contracts.
But not alone in that, we also will lose an opportunity of another guy who has come from Maine and wanted to manufacture here in the state.
We can't do it unless we pass this bill.
So there's so many pieces that we would be very sad if we don't pass this bill.
But like I say, the military installation, there was just no way we could figure it out.
We were joking how the only thing we could agree on is the title, military installation.
But the detail was was just it was just too much for us to go along with well to me this is um really important to me so i'm not willing to sign off on um even the underlying on even the underlying bill.
So you don't care about the beverage manufacturers and all the people who are actually doing business in the state.
We have taken care of a lot of the beverage manufacturers and the bills that we passed this year and in the past.
But this is really important to me and to me it's an important part of the national security.
So no.
Okay.
So we're just...
so So, Mr.
President.
Okay.
So, she refused to sign off.
So, even if we go forward, she's not going to sign off.
I think it's unfortunate.
We've seen so many examples of that air base in North Dakota, which I know that it was stopped.
But one of the most sensitive military installations in the country okay we're the portsmouth naval shipyard we have you know the facility and i i think it's in goffstown um this is a pretty narrow bill 10 miles around those facilities no that would have been fine if that's what it said.
But that's what it said.
No, it doesn't say that.
It says electric line, poles.
It says everything.
It is the biggest.
Pull it out.
Look at it.
It's the biggest laundry list you can imagine.
Remember, I asked you if you didn't agree with the language that was in that bill to come back to us with suggestions that we could entertain.
And here we are.
If you want to say, I guess, is that will, will everything that you cannot sell to anybody who's from, for the people's Republic of China, which I can't even imagine they would have the gall to try to come and buy land in, I guess, near Pease.
They sent a balloon right down the middle of this country.
Don't tell me about gall.
That was in the air.
That was in the air, right?
What?
It was over the continental United States.
Right.
They have row houses in Maine.
Let me understand here.
You're more worried about this esoteric event that somebody – I just can't even begin to imagine where they're going to buy, whether it's in New Boston or whether you're saying in Pease.
Of course, if there were Pease or the naval base, which is actually in Maine.
Okay.
So how are we going to, you know, I mean, did Maine pass this legislation?
How are we going to, how would you word it?
You're going to say that nobody can sell land to the People's Republic of China in Portsmouth.
It's not just sell.
It's lease.
Is that what you want to say?
Or lease, yeah.
No one can lease, buy in Portsmouth in Newington.
And then you have to clarify that, and we don't mean vacation rentals.
What you're saying is you can't, nobody of Chinese, it's not even Chinese, because we've had this discussion.
It was about Chinese.
The Chinese Communist Party, it is not Chinese nationals.
That is not the words that's in the bill.
That is the statement from the AG's office.
It's not what it says.
And I sent the language to you a month ago.
Let me ask you, do you really believe that there would be a purchase and sale agreement which will say CCCP on it?
I'd like to ask you if you really believed that the balloon that flew over the continental United States actually flew over the United States.
No, I know it flew over the United States.
And I also know that we found it in the water and we pulled it up and it didn't have anything, didn't do anything.
If you look at the drugs pouring across this border that have fentanyl, origins in China, if you look at TikTok, if you look at 20,000 or more military-aged Chinese males infiltrating our country, if you look at all of these things and the possibility of an attack on taiwan because they manufacture 90 percent of the chips in this bill why wouldn't you use common sense and pass a bill that has mild restrictions in it and if they're not good enough for you please give us a no it was your...
Give us an alternative.
No, there is no alternative.
It doesn't make any sense.
It makes absolutely no sense.
And if you really believe that our beverage manufacturers, we've done too much for them already, and that you said...
I did not say we've done too much for them.
I said we've done a lot for them.
Okay.
All right.
A lot versus too much.
I'm sorry.
And as far as I'm concerned, national security to me means more right now based on what's going on overseas.
If you want to drop it to military installations, our National Guard, fine.
Give me some language.
No, we're not interested in trying to solve that problem.
If you want to do to solve that problem, put in a bill next year.
I'm pretty sure that nothing's going to happen over the summer.
Put the bill in again, rewrite it, do it, start again.
But I'm saying we had a bill on the House side.
We interim studied it.
We didn't pass it.
We have a – as a matter of fact, we interim studied.
We have a study committee already on this issue.
We will absolutely be working on this come September.
The Commerce Committee will be working on this issue come September.
Is that not good enough is that good enough what what is the study committee did did study i mean this we know we we interim studied it that's what we did the the the original bill that was put in by the house Do we have that?
That's typically a polite way of killing it.
Not in commerce.
We had an agreement that any bill that was going to be a 10-10 partisan vote, that we would not pass it, that we would work on it to find some consensus.
It wasn't 10-10.
This bill, that bill in our committee.
It's an interim study.
1183.
And it was unanimous to interim study it.
What was the vote?
Unit 20-0.
22-0 to interim study it.
Which is really to us it's a polite way of killing it.
That may be true.
That's the way you guys feel about the second year of the session because you're all campaigning, you know, and, but we're, come September, some of us will not be campaigning, and we, we will do it, and I give my commitment to you that we will try to find some way we could pass this with narrow enough language that we feel comfortable with, but your, your version was was it was like every line was like it was it was too broad too wide and it wasn't focused and we will certainly I will commit my commitment to you is that we will we will do a serious study we'll let you know when we're having these meetings we can have the AG's office contribute and we certainly can have the that's who helped me draft draft it but if you want to change this to a study committee we already have a study committee I know a second study committee no just so I know that it's going to be studied I guarantee you I guarantee you, I guarantee you, we'll absolutely have a work session on 13...
1183.
1183, which is relative to prohibiting the sale of agricultural land and land essential to critical industries to China.
What was the bill that were told?
1183.
That was a House bill?
Yes, it was.
And I think it was the chairman who sponsored the bill.
Gorski.
Yeah.
Representative Gorski sponsored it.
So, yes, I'm not going to another fellow chairman.
I'm not going to squash his.
Can we recess?
I promise you we will work on this and we'll try to find some language that we can live with.
All right.
Let me have a conversation.
Thank you.
Yes, our thoughts.
I will offer to do an amendment creating a study committee because I want senators on that as well.
So I'll create a study committee to study the China issue with senators on it.
And the only other thing we would tell you, by the way, if you do do it, make sure that you then add in an effective date for that study committee to be upon passage and the report being the end of the year.
Typically November 1st, right?
Because right now it says section 11, which was this part of the bill, which starts January 1, which obviously we're going to move.
Turn that into a study committee.
The rest of the acts will take effect 60 days after passage.
So you're going to want your study committee to kick in sooner rather than later.
So that's the only thing I would say.
But that's fine.
If that's what you want, a chapter study committee.
Deadline's today at 4, right?
The deadline's today at 4.
Okay, so we...
I'll get it done.
You know, if you want us to come back, how much time are we going to need for this?
Get this.
I had no idea.
We're...
Right now we have 11 and...
11 I have cannabis, so I would say I have 12.
Yeah, we're on 12, but that's going to be quick.
So that should be quick.
So we can do it right after 12, 12.
12.30?
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
I'll see if they can get it done.
This is House Bill HB 1358.
Do you want to limit it just to land purchases, or do you want to broaden any kind of influence from the CCP in other areas?
I think I'm – Let her write it.
I'm just – We're okay with whatever chapter study you want to come up with.
I want to study the military installations, the National Guard, because they're in a different category, as well as the agricultural piece.
Because I do have concerns about the agricultural piece.
If I can ask, the federal government says that right now, if you're within 100 miles of a military base, you have to ask permission.
See, anybody from China has to ask permission.
If they grant permission, are we going to try to supersede them and say no?
That doesn't matter what the feds say.
That's something that we can study.
What the effect on the federal law versus state law.
Okay.
All right.
So we will end this hearing and bring it back to this community conference.
We'll take it back up at 1230 today.
I assume here.
Yeah, we'll say 201.
What room?
Right now, where we are.
In 201?
Yeah.
All right, thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, I think the way we left it was that you were going to contemplate some of the things we proposed.
So where are we?
Thank you, Mr.
Chair.
So I'm going to make some recommendations, and I'm going to ask that we then take a break until one o'clock to have you guys consider what we're going to be proposing to you and come back at one o'clock.
OK.
So the request is that the House secede to the Senate position with the following changes.
From Jason Osborne's amendment, Amendment 222H, we agree to add the House ask of provisions on line one through four, which was the passenger.
We would agree to the House ask of provisions six through 10, which has to do with the ATCs and priority in licensure.
We would agree with the House ask with the following changes on the decrim language.
We would agree to increase that to one ounce instead of the three quarters of an ounce.
To the two new asks that the House gave, we would agree to one new member of the Cannabis Control Commission by increasing under that section 318F22, Roman numeral 2, which is the Cannabis Control Commission, letter I, that increases from one to two of the representatives on the Cannabis Control Commission.
And lastly, based on the date, based on the original Senate amendment for moving from the not-for-profit to for-profit structure, and the problem being that we set a date in there that is before the effective date.
They had to have it done before we even made the law effective.
So we would agree to sections 9 through 23 that are the sections all dealing with the process of moving from not-for-profit to for-profit and all the language changes necessary.
We would agree to make that effective upon passage.
Upon passage.
And I'd ask now that we take a recess until 1 o'clock.
Do we need to?
Yes.
Simple statement.
You got something more you want to give us?
Yes.
Simple statement.
You got something more you want to mic give us?
Yes.
Okay.
Just stop there.
We'll see you.
Wait a minute.
Did I schedule something for one already?
No.
One o'clock is fine.
Back here.
Right back here.
Can we find it full of room?
I'm all set.
We're going out on the grass.
I'm just not sure how we get the YouTube stream over there.
Okay.
One o'clock on 13, 16, 33.
Thank you.
the committee conference on 1633.
So you actually can remember a bill.
So Mr.
Chair, I do need to make one minor change to the offer that I made earlier today.
It's not, it's, it's a correction.
That's all.
So when I gave you the last conversation about the for profit, the not-for-profit the for-profits i said sections 19 through 23 it should have been section 16 through 23.
okay so um who's taking good notes on all these i don't even have my my researcher here so i i guess we need to take something over to legislative services but do we have i How are we going to make sure we have all of it?
Well, I'm just thinking everything through here.
So can you, are your notes good enough that we could?
So I wrote out what the deal was.
As long as the committee of conference report reflects these, you'll get signatures.
Yep.
Okay.
So just so just to make sure for everybody yeah why don't you read it to it so the pending motion now is the house will accede to the senate amendment with the following amendment correct with the following changes so um on uh using i'm going to use two documents as our reference point.
I'm going to be using Representative Osborne's Amendment 2224H as I'm talking about some things, and I'm talking the original bill or the bill as amended by the Senate.
So those are the two documents I'm working from.
So relative to Amendment 2224H, we will agree to lines 1 through 4 be added to the bill or just merged into the bill.
We'll agree to lines 6 through 10 merged into the bill.
Starting on line 22, the temporary language, we will agree to the language but limit it to one ounce, not the two ounces that were in the amendment.
We will agree based on the original bill in Section 318-F22, Roman numeral 2, which is the Cannabis Control Commission makeup provision.
We will agree to add one more member under Section I, which is representatives of the cannabis industry, to increase the number of people on there.
And lastly, we'll agree to the sections dealing with the not-for-profit to for-profit conversion process in the Senate, in the original amended Senate bill, Section 16 through 23, which are on page...
I think it's 19.
It's actually 16.
16.
I don't think.
We verified.
16 through 23 which are on page i think it's 19.
it's actually 69 we verified 16 through 23 starting on page 31 and ending on page 34.
so we'll agree to bring that forward as upon passage those provisions all right any discussion um of the uh motion just make a comment?
Certainly.
Yeah.
I just want to say while we're going to accede to the suggestions made by the Senate, I do want to be clear that I personally am not, I'm signing this with a lot of angst and a lot of deliberation on my part, and I think some of my colleagues will feel the same way.
But however, I think that it's time that we legalize cannabis, and I think some of my colleagues will feel the same way but however I think that it's time that we um that we legalize cannabis and I think that this is the right move anybody else okay all those in favor say aye aye all those opposed so move you're gonna vote against it but but I am going to sign one.
Yes.
There you go.
The key element is he's signing it.
Yes.
For today.
So, okay.
Thank you.
Done deal.
So, okay, so Senator L Lang, do I need a copy of that?
Or.
Thank you.
so 12 30 so all right so So we're doing 1350A.
So the House will see to the Senate position.
Just listen with the deletion of the amendment of the section of the bill related to military installations and then replace that section will be replaced with a, so that must be section 10.
That will be replaced with the study committee in section 10 and section 11 has a new, probably has a new effective date.
Yeah, just make sure the effective dates are right because it's 25, Section 10 of this act will shake.
Upon a passage, the study committee takes place on passage, and then the rest of the act will take place in 60 days after passage.
And that includes, just so everybody understands, that includes the relative to tenant and contract manufacturers, allows pharmacists to administer influenza and COVID-19.
So we might listen.
That's been passed somewhere else.
That was passed.
Yeah, you'll know what I'm saying.
It's because you want to talk to a representative for itself because I think that was.
The pharmacists administering influenza and COVID-19 and other FDAda we divided oh we were just talking about divided the question on the floor in the senate and pulled it out because you guys passed forward that's right that was never in this that was never in here that's correct okay so then and then but it does include now a study committee for the military installation so it is just the tenant and contract manufacturers and it also has the study committee and can you put on the record that i will not be appointed to that take that up with the speaker do either do you want me to copy you on the request for that So when you put it in, they do it it and then as soon as it's done we get emailed it right oh i know i know i know but just yes no i think no i'm gonna be yeah that's fine no that's fine okay join the club oh wait i should be don't feel like don't feel like yelling at her see see Oh, wait, I should be.
Don't feel not yelling at her.
See?
No, wait a minute.
This is called an acceding.
The House is acceding to the Senate?
It doesn't have to, I guess.
It's true that it could be.
It's your bill.
So the Senate could be acceding to the House position with an amendment.
That's true.
Let's do it that way.
All right.
Yeah, the Senate is acceding to the House position with the amendment of the study committee.
China.
I will be in Paris.
Seriously, I will be in Paris in August.
Oh, and I'll be in Ireland.
There you go.
We'll have a meeting in Europe.
That's okay.
Your chapter study.
When are you going to have your meeting?
Who's going to be the first?
So the first person is going to have to be...
I'll be gone in two weeks.
Okay.
We're all in agreement?
Yeah.
All right.
All those in favor say weeks.
Okay.
We're all in agreement?
Yeah.
All right.
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
Those opposed.
Thank you.